there's no time
[Music]
o'clock
all right episode 129. I'm sure there's
a lot of people waiting for this one
this is Nostradamus also known as
Nostradamus I taught this man everything
he knows about how to see tomorrow he
news
Thomas The Man Who Saw tomorrow yeah
I've been drinking
[Laughter]
yeah like I said on our previous couple
of shows we're starting to record
several episodes at once yeah so
sometimes some of these may be drunker
than usual but that's like probably you
know what I mean it's okay Jenny's done
done all the research I know this real
well and we've got it already structured
and there's it's outlined we know
exactly what we're talking about we got
this we got this dude
what's up the intros we used to do the
news we don't do the news anymore
remember I used to sing the news we
forgot about that well you can still
sing it if you want the news the news
I'll tell you what the news is
Jenny's book is selling fantastic guys I
really want to thank you guys for yes
thank you we have a lot of repeat
customers a lot of new customers
and I got like awesome reviews on it
yeah you guys kick ass yeah if you have
the book and you haven't left a review
yet please leave one and I swear to God
before the end of the year I'm gonna
have [ __ ] volume three out yeah I
swear volume one uh also unseen hand and
all the other ones are all gonna be
re-recorded she's already got involved
I'm re-recording volume one already yeah
she's a moment yeah about a third of the
way by the time you hear this it may be
done actually it might be yeah it might
be done by then we'll see because uh
she's uh because of the new uh dead room
that I built for she's able to get it
done real real fast real good too
because she can stand up and sit there
and you know emote while she's reading
and we're gonna you know it's gonna be
good it's gonna be good because like
seriously imagine this like the the
audiobook that I did at volume two yeah
that was recorded you guys would laugh
in the closet in my office with like it
wasn't even talented it was like
comforters comforters right he like rigs
like he took these comforters and like
put them like all around the inside like
to muffle the sound
legged and like read into the microphone
and I can only read for about an hour or
two before my feet fell asleep see
because the standards the the standards
that uh the audible is now demanding
they're good standards actually it has
to have a certain Baseline noise
it has to be below minus 60 decibels
right so uh that was the only way to
meet that but the new Dead room does it
so it's gonna be fine and like I said we
actually got real soundproofing foam uh
we got that [ __ ] we got a folding shelf
that comes out that we installed on the
wall much better mic and uh you know so
I can put the laptop in the microphone
like right at height where I can like
stand up and yeah read which I prefer to
read standing up because
I because when I read out loud like I
like to like move my hands because you
know you guys that watch the show on
YouTube you know that I move my hands
around well when you go to a studio
we've been to real Studios before for
you know radio shows for various things
you're standing up when you're doing
that and that really helps voice actors
a lot because you can move you can like
you can you can either right when you're
sitting you're kind of like crunched up
and yeah and there were some complaints
on
um part one and on all of them about the
audio quality so we're going to take
care of that I'm you know we're we're
always endeavoring to improve our game
yeah and uh even the read on um unseen
hand there's a truck driver out there I
forgot your name but if you're listening
yeah he said that your read was kind of
dead and that's my fault I I did that
yeah uh a lot a lot of people now you
know they want your kind of normal
animated delivery that you do on the
show yeah I was thinking that except for
that all the copious swearing right I
was thinking that unseen hand might
sound better if it was just real kind of
dry and clinical but evidently it's if
you're a truck driver it's not really a
good listen well people just want to
listen to my
my funny voice I guess or my regular
voice not my funny voice yeah so for
unseen hands this is what I talk like
all the time I'm seeing hand in a couple
months in addition two will come out and
it'll it'll be a better read yeah yeah
so we are like juicier read
well I don't know a more voluptuous read
yeah that's right amazed myself from my
sexy voice my phone sex voice I don't
have one of those I don't know what
you're talking about but yeah so uh the
camera moves uh yeah that's baby cooking
that baby Cookie is behind my sleeping
behind the camera I think it did move it
did move a little bit yeah
put that one she's uh she obviously
thought that was not a good angle so
yeah she's always like trying to she's
strived to improve the show just like we
all are so what's on the list here well
the only other uh the only other shout
out that I had was just hey if you
haven't seen the last movie
retrospective it was deep red otherwise
known as profunda Rosso Dario argento's
very famous Jello movie so if you
haven't seen that and you're into that
kind of [ __ ] then go back and watch that
[ __ ] and if you're a regular listener
and you'd like to be a a patron please
um join us on patreon we're trying to
reach one thousand dollars a month we're
actually at probably close to five five
hundred now yeah we're getting close to
500. yeah we're about halfway there yeah
so we're about halfway there and like I
said I've really really been making an
effort to I post Early Access to all the
shows now like a day ahead of time
um you know I'm trying to post like cute
little videos I posted one of you like
before we were going out to the club and
[ __ ] like we don't have that many
patrons but we have badass patrons they
pay a lot yeah so a lot of people give
you like 20 a month 10 bucks a month but
uh you know if you guys just want to
come in for a five or a three dollar a
month or a two dollar month you can just
write it in fine it's like amazing that
anyone gives anything like I love that
you guys because I get messages all the
time about how much you love us and
everything like that I'm like that's so
awesome now if you guys only want to
give like a dollar a month
you might want to reconsider that I
think because if it's if it's like a
dollar I think patreon gets most of that
it's like they do but the last I heard I
think they they get like 75 cents of
that I mean overall though it's like
patreon doesn't really take that big of
a chance
um you know I don't really think of it
in terms of like oh somebody just gives
a dollar and they take 75 cents because
I you know I I get it all as one okay
you know lump sums so I remember hearing
that people that paid a dollar for other
people is just like patreon gets most of
that money anyway so you you know you
might as well not give but yeah but uh
you know two dollars is actually I would
think probably the uh when you give two
dollars at least we'll get one dollar
yeah you know which like I said not not
a big difference between one dollar or
two dollar on your end right yeah
exactly right and like I said I
appreciate anybody giving it it's a
really I appreciate anybody sharing the
show or telling other people about the
show [ __ ] you don't even have to like
give us money it's like awesome that you
do but you know just and it just
spreading the word around that helps too
yeah and merch has been uh selling too
yeah really cool shirts you know uh we
usually have links in the description I
swear to God I'm going to do more I just
we got to get more shirts get around to
it you guys and I know I say this every
time but it's like I'm so I feel like I
try to get ahead on [ __ ] yeah and then
she is so busy it intervenes and I'm
just like so busy I feel like I can
never get ahead of stuff she's been
doing album cover she's got she just did
another black metal album cover she's
doing all kinds of stuff packaging for
uh uh healing butterfly which is uh they
make matcha tea matcha tea and turmeric
stuff and that would that's just
delicious and they didn't even pay me to
say that but with your guys's help you
know and hopefully with their Book Sales
and everything but maybe one day she can
get away with from uh graphic design and
go straight writing books yeah making
audio I like doing graphic design though
like I don't mind I don't mind doing it
because I do a lot of it for uh for
bands and for you know goth Industrial
area and yeah that's fine I don't mind
doing that and it's like you know what I
mean yeah I still need to get paid and
[ __ ] like that because I got bills you
but you know what I mean it's that stuff
is a lot more enjoyable to do than
graphic design isn't big money but it's
quick money
they pay you right then yeah it's not
like writing a book where you got to
work for a year and it's gonna be a year
before you see anything on it yeah but
you know hey money's money man one of
these days it's all about the hustle
yeah
everybody knows that in this new age
she's moving the camera again baby
Cookie why are you playing with the
camera because she's she's the camera
woman she's camera woman yeah but yeah
like I said in this economy you gotta
man you gotta have side gigs going it's
like I got three well actually my whole
thing is side gigs I'm all side they're
all side gigs I don't have a full-time
job because I got I got laid off in uh
2016. yeah and uh after a couple shaky
months of having no money I actually
stole a couple of graphic design clients
from my old
job yeah
and uh yeah yeah yeah and the and a
couple of the ones that I stole from
them like gave me references to other
ones that have been like some of my
biggest well that old job shut down
graphic design they weren't gonna they
would well that shit's closed now it's
closed now it's gone we went but we went
by there we don't usually go by there
but we went by there the other day and
it's closed I had a fig I figured that
was gonna happen so it's not like
stealing it's more like inheriting
that's a good way of looking at it yeah
yeah they're gone so you you got their
clients and I was talking to somebody on
YouTube about this uh that I always
wanted to like work at home have my own
home office [ __ ] like that and I have
that now and that's awesome
um I thought that it would give me more
free time that was incorrect no uh I
have much less free time but you're not
commuting true yeah yeah because that
was a lot of wasted time because I mean
I have a boss except me yeah and all I'm
doing is trying my and yeah stupid
exactly
actually all I'm doing what the what the
market wants yeah and you know you
always need a second set of eyes on
something yeah it is good to have yeah
you know but it's I can't complain
because a lot of people you know and
particularly you know if people want to
get away from jobs it's like yeah it's
shaky because like I said I don't know
how much money I'm gonna make per month
it's like some months I do really good
some months I'm kind of worried about it
um but you have never failed to meet
demands though yeah you've always paid
your bills I always I worry about well
except for the I had a couple shaky
months like I said right after I first
got left that was a long time ago but
that was a long time ago that was a
couple you were still in transition yeah
so but other than that I've been doing
okay some months like I said I don't
have any extra money and I would like to
be able to take a vacation at some point
yeah it'll come soon but me I'm all
military pension yeah military pension
you live in the Sweet Life man I get I
get my pay yeah he just gets money no
matter what I'm fully covered
yeah but yeah me I kind of get a I gotta
hustle for every like every book but you
know
yeah that's all right well you know when
you win a lawsuit against the US
government you don't really you know
don't lift it don't look at guitars man
it took a long time to win that one
though it did yeah you went through a
lot of [ __ ] I'm not saying that but yeah
yeah it's but yeah he's he's taken care
of yeah you know what I mean he's he's
got it all sorted out I'm hopeful I'm
hoping I'll get to that point one day
you're gonna exceed it you're gonna
exceed me me and you together are gonna
create an empire
that's an Empire
we're like audio books we're like one of
those power couples
all right so
do you want to talk about Nostradamus
it's time to talk about not Nostradamus
now
when did you first hear about
Nostradamus you know what it was either
it was probably the first time that I
saw I don't know I was gonna say the
first time I saw a man who saw tomorrow
that's right that Orson Welles
documentary but that was like 1981 so it
might have been earlier than that I saw
in 81 that was before Mammoth Mountain
Poltergeist happened yeah and it was on
HBO and yeah that that show just totally
mesmerized me yeah I believe is she
moving the camera again well it's just
her butt here that's good she's not
mating I'm gonna put it I'm gonna put it
over here she's not meaning to she's
doing it she because she's back there
like [ __ ] around like taking a bath
yeah and her little butt is just like
scooting it
it's about right okay yeah she's right
in the middle of the she's moving the
camera yeah she's sitting on the court
is why yeah she wants to be involved
that's all she's making that noise
yeah she doesn't um
she doesn't meow all that much no but
she makes these weird purring but she
makes it but she doesn't open her mouth
though she makes it's like in her throat
she goes yeah
and then she does that for everything
yeah yeah we're talking about you yeah
she's looking around okay but yeah so I
probably read about because like I said
when I was a teenager
um you know when I was a kid I was like
super into like paranormal books and
stuff like that and Nostradamus was like
especially in the 70s there was all kind
of like this paranormal like Mysteries
kind of books and it was like all kind
of [ __ ] about Nostradamus in there and I
have to say too it's like I'm gonna show
you right here and I've probably shown
this book yeah I'm taking it
um I've shown this book on a couple
other options strange stories amazing
facts this is a Reader's Digest book
came out in the 70s 1974 I believe
um they have like this huge big spread
in here on Nostradamus which is probably
the first place you should show it to
the camera yeah it's like Europe's
greatest profit right there and then
they have two pages of all his like
quote-unquote predictions that were
super accurate got stuff about Napoleon
were you young whippersnappers we used
to have these things called books they
actually had Pages books are making a
big comeback actually print books yeah I
used to love those things in uh back
before we had the internet we'd read
these books and you didn't you couldn't
answer questions of course you couldn't
really do any research outside of this
so you were constantly left with
questions when you'd read them and it
kind of gave you this Eerie feeling that
that kind of you know that what's a good
way to put it it was just they were kind
of eerie to read because you couldn't
debunk it if it was [ __ ] and you
couldn't really confirm it if it was
true you just kind of had to take the
books well yeah that was the thing and
like I remember when I read this [ __ ]
when I was a kid
um and all of these say I'm like man
that sounds legit that dude was probably
psychic and everything it's like now you
can like now look deeper into it and be
like yeah that probably wasn't it's you
know that's part of growing up again
like when you're a kid like you read all
this stuff it's like yeah that sounds
like it there was always fake news and
that was that's what we'll get into
something piece by piece
Nostradamus was a soothsayer and that
was a job back in his day yeah okay
although he didn't start out as done no
he did a bunch of other stuff he was a
scientist it was kind of he was what
they would have considered a scientist
back in those days he did um here's the
thing he was uh they usually call him a
physician and an astrologer although I
should have to say physician I don't
know how accurate that is it didn't mean
the same thing well and he'd never
finished medical school
but he never did finish medical school
so it wasn't like he most of his life
like before he started doing uh The Seer
gig uh he actually worked as an
apothecary
um so that's kind of most of his youth
was spent doing that kind of stuff just
like mixing up yeah we're talking about
the 1500s yeah you know so
the the state-of-the-art technology was
very laughable you know if you could
read Galen you were you were a doctor
yeah and if you know Galen wrote a lot
and that was one of his first books was
actually a translation of Galen yeah so
and uh
you know
Galen
it
Galen did have a good holistic
philosophy
uh he didn't have a very good knowledge
of internal organs there's a lot of
Galen himself is an entirely big is an
entirely different subject we'd have to
do a show about him uh but for nearly a
thousand years
Galen was the go-to guy when it came to
medicine and it was because he wrote so
much but that was one of his downfalls
Galen wrote so much stuff that it
contradicted itself he wrote some every
day because he forgot 10 years ago all
right and a lot of stuff that he would
write he couldn't really back it up with
scientific principle they didn't really
have the scientific method back then
but in general Galen gave kind of good
advice
uh if you were in the Middle Ages
or even you know
you were in better hands with someone
who had read Galen than someone who was
just making [ __ ] up
I didn't say that you know what I mean
it wasn't modern medicine but it was
better better than what the average
person you know because a lot of the
medicine at the time like would actively
harm me would it hurt you react it was
Bloodlines it was probably better to do
nothing right right you know what I mean
yeah but you that's the thing I think we
mentioned this before when we were I
don't remember what show we were doing
but we were talking about Galen and how
he like wrote so much and everything the
problem with a lot of particularly
medieval medicine and stuff like that is
because a lot of it was you know what
they would call today argument from
Authority whereas you know someone in
the ancient world said this so therefore
so they were just repeating it yeah um
they didn't have a scientific method
they couldn't check things themselves
they said oh well that's what he said so
that must be the case in a way Galen
improved the situation but he also
caused it to stagnate because if you
said anything against the teachings of
Galen then you were just [ __ ] wrong
yeah well the problem was Galen was
wrong about a lot of [ __ ] yeah okay so
yeah eventually the scientific method
disproved Galen yeah which you know
that's identification of authority
things is always like a bad idea yeah
just saying and um just off the top of
my head I don't think Galen had much of
a surgical knowledge
I don't remember not a lot of people did
at the time no no although what was
strange is that a lot that there were
ancient
Roman surgeons that could actually do
all kinds of stuff that uh that the
medievals couldn't even they couldn't
even do that in the Renaissance a lot of
it had to do with sports medicine that
they could cut into a gladiator and fix
tendons and you know
actually repair damage I feel like the
bricks and the ribbons had a lot of [ __ ]
right
um but then a lot of the knowledge was
lost or it was lost or messed up like in
the transition like Library of
Alexandria got burned and a lot of the
information was lost and never passed
down but uh according to uh accounts of
the day
ancient Romans and ancient Greeks could
actually do uh cosmetic surgery like
breast reductions and facelifts that's
[ __ ] amazing I wonder if that's
really true yeah evidently they could
and they did it without anesthesia oh no
thank you it was just a very sharp
scalpels they would give them wine
they'd get them drunk well but that was
that was their version of anesthesia
although that's bad because that makes
your blood that thins your blood one of
the things that Romans were about was
doing breast reduction on men
so they would actually make incisions to
get in there and they pull fat out and
they'd suture it back up and that would
infer that they had to have had very uh
they had to have a concept of
sterilization yeah because you couldn't
do that with dirty tools you'd kill the
guy from infection yeah they definitely
didn't have antibiotics
so that means that they knew about
sterilization
which the medievals did not know because
they're just like man I'm just gonna
wipe my ass with this hand and they're
gonna reach it right you're good yeah
yeah why did he die I can't figure it
out I don't know man
right just God wanted it that way I
guess but let's get around let's get
back so all right so Nostradamus very
famously born Michelle de nostradam
in 1503 uh not sure of the exact date of
his it was either December 14th or
December 21st uh he was born in Provence
now not a lot is known about his youth
um and I discovered that much of the
like a lot of the stories that kind of
circulate about his upbringing about his
Youth and stuff like that
um don't really have any sources to
support them there's a lot of legendary
stuff one of the sources that I
remembered said that his history was
vague it is he was probably Jewish he
was Jewish they do know that in those
days they tried to kind of his family
was Jewish but had converted to
Catholicism either in his father's
generation or his grandfather which made
which may explain why his past was kind
of clouded because in those days if he
had a Jewish past you might want to not
talk about that because it's better yes
it's better to reinforce your new
Catholic identity that seems to be the
case and like I said I I've seen like
because I read you know read the
Wikipedia page I read the Britannica
page I read like pages from Believers
pages from Skeptics stuff like that that
the sources seem to say the family was
Jewish but either in his father's
generation or his grandfathers they
converted to Catholicism probably to
avoid persecution yeah now here's which
a lot of families did at the time now
here's the thing for the for uh for the
modern people to understand uh when you
talk about
um
when you talk about Jews hiding their
past this was not a racial thing this is
a religious thing because the Jews and
the Catholics were basically they were
the same race they'd been in that same
area for
1500 years almost 2 000 years this
wasn't really a racial thing it was all
about religion yeah even during the uh
um you know during the time of tokomata
they were trying to just get Jews to
convert to Catholicism they weren't
trying to wipe out People based on race
yeah just making that clear
but the thing about like I said that's
pretty standard like you know about his
history most people uh you know accept
that yeah
um now a lot of [ __ ] will say that it is
youth he was uh taught by his
grandfathers or his maternal grandfather
who's talking about the Kabbalah and
stuff like that there is no contemporary
source to support that
um so they're not really sure about much
of anything like
from his childhood you know because
there's all this stuff about oh he was a
super intelligent student and all this
other kind of stuff there's all these
Legends like surrounding his childhood
um but there's no contemporary sources
to support that now they do know that he
entered the
University of Avignon in when he was 14
years old in order to study medicine
however he was only there for a year but
then the um he left because there was
like an outbreak at the plague and like
you know I guess a lot of they were
closing down the school or whatever now
he started working as an apothecary at
about this time later on he went to get
his Doctorate but he was only at the
school for you know a short time before
apparently the university found out that
he had been an apothecary which was
considered quote unquote a manual trade
which wasn't something that they
endorsed so they kicked him out yeah so
he never did get and they do have the
expulsion notice it is on record
um so that is a fact that he was kicked
out of medical school before he obtained
his Doctorate so he never became like an
actionable doctor he never got there in
case you don't know what an apothecary
is an apothecary is is basically an
old-fashioned pharmacist
yeah it's basically what they did they
made medicine yeah
right and it seems like he kind of went
around doing that kind of thing where he
was like into like herbal Metals
medicines and like kind of traveling
around like making medicines now like I
said there's a lot of Legends about him
after he got kicked out of school like
where he was going around combating the
plague there's a lot of
um
kind of apocryphal stories about how
ahead of his time it was it's like oh he
refused to bleed patience
um he knew about hygiene like he was
like Hey everybody needs to wash their
hands and do this and that and the other
I'm not sure how true any of that is
because like I said there are probably
just temporary sources they're just
trying to make it seem like he was like
super ahead of his time
um he did invent
uh something it was like a logic lozenge
it was called The Rose pill uh that
supposedly uh was made from rose hips
which has vitamin C in it apparently and
supposedly was like helpful to plague
victims or whatever a lot of the reason
why authors are making these claims
about them is because evidently he had a
high customer satisfaction rate yeah
which meant that many of his people
probably survived yeah they survived and
he must have been doing the right but
they might have survived anyway we don't
we don't know we don't we don't know but
what they're inferring is well he was
popular because his P his his uh
patients survived therefore he must have
been pretty clean yeah he must have been
doing things uh uh correctly things that
other guys weren't doing correctly and
that were ending it with bad you know
results yeah which usually not washing
your damn hands had a lot to do with it
it's really funny to me how long it took
for people to figure out that just
washing your hands would save like 80
percent of your patients yeah just don't
stick your [ __ ] covered hands into
people's abdomen except no concept of
microbiology if you couldn't see it it
didn't exist that was really thinking of
the time although they believed in like
demons and angels and goddesses yeah and
you can't see that but they just
couldn't so you'd think they could have
extrapolated but they never did the idea
of single-celled organisms you know
infecting people that just wasn't wasn't
in them that must have seemed like weird
like magic or something like I feel like
if somebody had said that at the time
they'd been like eventually the
microscope came I think that was 1600s
I'm not sure oh no I think that was 17.
1700s okay okay but uh I think if I
remember if I remember correctly there
were theories
in the 16 15 and 1600s of microorganisms
but it wasn't proven until later on when
they had microscopes and they could say
there they are
yeah but uh it's like see I'm not crazy
there's little bitty things right but it
just would have been Advanced Theory it
would have been almost like quantum
physics back in those days you know
something could be so small you can't
see it and it might attack but it's like
no yeah no no yeah
I'm just gonna stick my dirty ass hands
in people's you know what I mean but
yeah so
apparently uh so at this stage he's
traveling around Europe with his
Apothecary stuff and everything like
that now he did marry and have two
children
um but apparently they all died
presumably because of the plague which
killed you know a large percentage of
people at the Times ravaging through
Europe many times so he did marry again
later on and have uh more children but
this was something that and I've I've
watched some documentaries about him
there was actually one that was made for
I believe the Discovery Channel that was
actually kind of critical of his stuff
and it was like pointing out like
mistakes and his prophecies and stuff
like that but it still repeated a lot of
them by a lot uh the biographical
information about him that is not uh
sourced it's you know what I mean it's
most of it's based on stuff that was
written much later yeah you know all
these kind of stories about it which
means Legend yeah so like I said I don't
think anybody knows much of anything
about him before he started writing like
his prophecies you know basically have
his books and his reputation yeah I
think a lot of his reputation actually
comes from him though I think he's the
source it's yeah and I don't know like
okay we talked about this a little bit
on our Edgar Casey show which um you
know he was another guy it's it's kind
of different because he didn't really
make future prophecies he just mostly
made like medical diagnoses and things
but
um I feel like
Edgar Casey I'm willing to give him the
benefit of the doubt because I don't
think he was deliberately trying to
defraud anyone Nostradamus I'm not so
sure yeah well there was a certain there
was a way to make money back then maybe
we can get into that later he I think he
knew what he was doing
yeah very much using a method for sooth
saying
although maybe he believed in that maybe
he believed he might have believed it
sure yeah yeah now his whole thing was
that
you know after the death of his family
and the plague and whatnot or so The
Story Goes he starts getting more into
the occult now
there's been a lot made of the fact that
like oh he had to like write these
quatrains in like this weird
uh light like you would mix up languages
and you were like poetically so like he
would get away from the Inquisition but
I don't feel like the Inquisition really
had him in its sights
um you know astrology was uh a pretty
respected science at the time it wasn't
seen as yeah it was heretical or
anything like that
um I don't think he was doing anything
that really would have brought him to
the attention of the Inquisition plus
his clientele was wealthy that too and
the church wouldn't want to step on
their toes a lot you know yeah over
stuff like this like every now and then
he would get like brought in and stuff
but it's like no it seemed like nothing
major
um you know what I mean it's it just
seems like
well they probably wanted Kickbacks the
church did that kind of stuff a lot
right I feel like that was kind of the
extent of it I mean he never got
arrested he never got it wasn't like
Galileo where he got like put in hell
like you know prison or anything like
that well Nostradamus wasn't saying
anything that challenged The Authority
yeah exactly and he was uh you know a
lifelong Catholic you know he always
kind of came he so he didn't really have
any beef with like the Catholic Church
it doesn't seem like and they didn't
really seem to have any beef with him
um I don't think he was any particular
danger of being burned at the stake or
anything like that with the [ __ ] he was
coming up with well and besides that
like the [ __ ] he was coming up with is
so [ __ ] yeah vague they could have
like applied to anything it's
conceivable knowing the history of the
church what would happen is is that he's
doing things that are kind of
kind of slightly questionable maybe it's
good to bring him in and have him
questioned and make it make sure like
make sure that he makes a donation to
the church yeah you know the church was
about money yeah they're just kind of
like hey maybe we'll burn you a mistake
if you don't like you're like hey no
it's Thomas what you been up to uh is
this stuff Godly it is okay well why
haven't you given to the church oh you
give them to the church okay good yeah
okay make your donation I'll go [ __ ] out
of here yeah yeah because the church
wanted their cut Yeah well yeah always
always the church wants still
even hundreds of years later I think
that was probably like the ex based on
my memory I haven't read about you
you're the one that's done the research
recently based on my memory the church
didn't really want anything from him so
he was in good standing yeah like I said
he got brought in like once or twice on
like minor [ __ ] but then they were just
like yeah whatever just get out of here
and because I feel like like I said
astrology was not verboten um you know
the [ __ ] he was doing was not
really not was not sanctioned I mean
astrology was fine that was a science
that was a science then so it wasn't
like he wasn't like indulging in magic
or anything like that or witchcraft or
anything like that they didn't see it
like astrology had been a shot I'm doing
the quotation air quotes Scientology
excuse me
it had been a science going all the way
back to the Greek era yeah
so they didn't the church the church
wasn't threatened by that right they
didn't see it as anything particularly
Supernatural
um you know like I said later on he
actually married again he married a
wealthy uh woman named Ann ponzard and
they had six children
um and then at this stage he started uh
publishing books now there is one
apocryphal story that I wanted to
mention because this was one that comes
up in a lot of like uh you know
paranormal stuff that's about uh
Nostradamus that one time in his youth
at some unspecified time
he walks up to this lowly
Friar or like a monk uh whose name was
whose name was uh Felice Peretti and he
like bends down and like starts kissing
his robe and stuff and everyone's like
what the [ __ ] are you doing man it's
like you know why are you kissing is
just this little Friar or whatever and
he's like oh I have to pay my respect to
the pope or whatever and then like later
on that guy became Pope 6 to the fifth
but you know what I mean that that's
kind of a thing that was written later
on yes you don't know if that was
written retroactively you know I think
everything about him was
there's not a lot of contemporary
because here's the thing
um in the 1970s there was like all these
books uh you know actually the first one
the best known one that came out uh came
out in 1947 it was reprinted like many
times over the ensuing decades and then
there were a couple other ones came out
in the 60s and 70s and stuff and I think
a lot of that stuff repeated a lot of
the stories from his Youth and all this
kind of stuff like of his early
biography
and a lot of his
um you know predictions but in the 1980s
they actually found like a cache of like
his personal correspondence
um they found a lot of the first
editions like of his work and stuff like
that so a lot of the stuff that is
commonly repeated about Nostradamus
is not
um evident in the Contemporary Source
like when he was alive so in other words
it's more legendary so it's Morse it was
stuff that came about like later like
after he was dead like other writers
that were referring back to him you know
kind of made up well he had a reputation
so we had to assume that after his death
people could have made money writing
books about Nostradamus and they did
right so you can say oh yeah Rose Thomas
he did this and this and that and
there's no source for it yeah because
here's the here's the thing and I've
even seen this on several documentaries
about him they said that one of the ways
he would get his predictions about the
future was that he would um do what they
call scrying where he would look into
like a bowl of water you know you know
which is essentially like a crystal ball
type of thing and he would look in there
and have these Visions about the future
now the only contemporary Source like he
had written kind of a letter
um talking about how he got his visions
um and the only thing that he said was
he's like it was like that he didn't say
that he actually did that he said it was
kind of like the old like delphic Oracle
where they would look into this bowl of
water he's like it was like that but not
you know what I mean so I think people
were like taking it too literally you
know what I'm saying
um so we don't know if he actually
looked into a bowl of water or yeah it
doesn't he never mentioned it into a
flame too some people have said that to
you but like I said the only reference
to that in his actual writings like from
the time he was alive okay um he was
just comparing it to that okay he just
said you know like the delphic Oracle he
would look into like a bowl of water or
you would look into a flame or something
he's like it's like that he's putting
himself into a trance he's looking into
something yeah basically what he would
do was meditate and then he would like
have these ideas and then he would write
them down now another thing that a lot
of people don't know about Nostradamus
is that a lot of the [ __ ] that he wrote
he straight straight up ripped off from
other authors he took a lot of his
predictions from Revelation obviously
but also from a lot of other classical
writers swetonius Plutarch
um there was one book in particular
which was called the mirabilis Liber I
hope I'm pronouncing that correctly
which was kind of a compilation of like
a lot of uh prophecies predictions and
stuff like that and this book was
actually quite famous in the 1520s but
because
um a lot of it was kind of inscrutable
and it had like kind of like a lot of
these weird things it's it's
um it's Legacy didn't really last so
Nostradamus had read it and he actually
ended up kind of paraphrasing a lot of
its prophecies and Publishing them to
French later on and a lot of people
didn't realize that that was what he was
parenting we don't really know where
this book came from well they know when
it was posed published in 1522 okay and
it was like a compilation of like
different prophecies by different by
various people they know where those
prophecies came from or is this yeah
yeah yeah okay yeah so so he kind of um
he took a lot from that so a lot of his
work was not original let's just say
that he was just like compiling he's
compiling things from other sources
translating them into French and then
writing these kind of like vague
quatrains
um you know and obviously if you know
anything about Nostradamus which most
people do
um he wrote you know he started out
writing kind of like medical books like
medical cookbooks like I said he did a
translation of Galen uh then after that
he started writing almanacs
um and he started writing those in you
know around the like 15 10s 15 11
something like that and he started
writing those like every year sometimes
he'd do more than one a year and he
started like putting prophecies into his
almanacs and they were so popular that
he decided Well I'm just gonna do like a
whole series
of books about prophecies that he was
going to call you know the prophecies
and he put them into what called
centuries yeah and these are what he's
really known for the next couple
thousand years and that is obviously
what he's still known for to this day
now so this is his original material
right he starts off kind of like paying
homage to the uh well the office that
came before him as well
a lot of these ones are still okay that
okay so when he starts getting into this
writing his own centuries
he's rebooting
prophecies from authorities that he
respects yeah okay yes okay and it
should be noted too that and here's
something that a lot of Skeptics have
said about
nostradamus's quote-unquote prophecies
is that okay
now the problem being that none of his
original editions survive like probably
there are some that came out while he
was still alive I believe only one of
his uh centuries uh compilations was
published while he was alive the other
ones were published after he was dead
um and the problem is that
people that you know in recent times
that have tried to translate these
prophecies and kind of make them fit you
know particular events in history uh one
they don't know anything about 16th
century French
um there's another thing too is that
Nostradamus would often write in not
just straight 16th century French but he
would mix in Latin and uh you know
Provencal which was kind of like his uh
you know local dialect
um he would mix in Greek he would
sometimes mix in anagrams According to
some sources because uh he didn't want
to get in trouble for doing this
particular thing that's usually the
reason given so
these um these quadrains that he writes
I have seen wildly different
translations of these if you ask me
though I think he's doing that on
purpose so yeah so you can make
alternate yeah alternate interpretations
of them yeah you know what I mean that
way it increases increases your chance
of getting a hit
yeah yeah and like I said I watched one
documentary that was made for the
Discovery Channel and uh
uh Richard Wiseman who is a very uh
famous psychologist and he's written
several books many of which I've read he
said on this documentary he's like we're
gonna play uh Nostradamus roulette he's
like whereas I'm gonna pick one thing I
think it was 23 red or something like
that and I'm just gonna keep spinning
until I get it right he's like because
that's what you do it's like you give
long enough time because he didn't
really date any of his stuff there was
only a couple that were dated
um he's like you give it enough time
something that vaguely sounds like that
is gonna happen yeah I mean if you do
them with fortune tellers you know the
more vague you are the more the better
off I mean if I can just go up to you
and go look you will meet a man
whoa whoa yeah well we all mean how'd
you know that if if yeah we all meet men
yeah that could mean anything mean
anything just that uh you know a lot of
his well I'm writing into that next time
it's too early I like Nostradamus I
think he was very stylish okay uh yeah
his writings I think were
intriguing uh there's a lot of stuff
that he wrote that just
if you interpret it a certain way
through English through the English
language
it sounds awful close
uh but well we but the statistics are
involved yeah and like I said even just
okay so this book that I showed you at
the beginning that came out in 1974 and
1976 I can't remember but it has like
some translations of the quatrains and
they are wildly different from the ones
that I saw on various other websites
they're wildly different from the ones I
saw in various documentaries about uh
Nostradamus including the including the
men who saw tomorrow so
these are very
um you know the the vague way because
here's the whole here's the thing
Nostradamus apparently
believed that
history he was an astrologer first and
foremost even though other astrologers
at the time thought that he was full of
[ __ ] and he was doing it wrong oh yeah
yeah so in his day they were they were
bagging on him yeah okay even in the day
okay
but his whole thing was that he believed
that history and astrology were cyclical
which isn't entirely wrong but it does
seem to be cyclical yeah but so the
whole thing that he would do was that
if he wanted to quote unquote predict
some [ __ ]
he would look into the past to when the
astrological
um you know when the planets were
aligned in the similar kind of way and
he's like okay well the X thing happened
when those planets were aligned so maybe
in the future when those planets are
aligned again a similar [ __ ] will happen
right so if you're like reading some of
his quatrains a lot of them seem to
refer to [ __ ] that happened in the past
like before he was born
um and that's on purpose because he
thought that things would repeat again
and again so what he would do when he
was trying to predict the future was
that he would go back to past events
that happened at that particular time
and then he would project It Forward
into the future right and which actually
is very scientific from his point of
view it is kind of yeah and actually it
kind of works out because
in a way history is kind of cyclical and
if you couch it in vague enough terms
right then you know
many years down the line people can
interpret you know a various thing that
he said because a lot of his [ __ ] was
really vague and he's like oh yeah that
can refer to this that and the other
I've looked at this cyclical nature in
history and I think a lot of it has to
do with Generations yeah it's more
generational uh more than anything else
you know but let's let's keep going yeah
so you know what I'm saying like I said
the the most popular books about
Nostradamus you know in the 20th century
didn't start coming out to the late
1940s and then
you know there were a bunch of other
ones kind of interpreted and like I said
they all have kind of slightly different
interpretations of a lot of his
quatrains which a lot of linguists have
kind of [ __ ] on because they're like you
know you are
reading into these quatrains probably
something that he didn't intend you were
like twisting things because it should
be noted that even though these are
supposedly prophecies nobody ever
never read one of nostradamus's
prophecies and knew exactly what that
was like before it happened it's always
after the fact right and then they're
like oh he must have been talking about
that oh he must have been talking about
the French Revolution oh he must have
been talking about so it's useless for
prediction right which in a way why is
that it that's not enough to come to
pass in order in order for you to be
able to step it into one of those things
right and I feel like
I mean I've read some of these sites
I've read some of this [ __ ]
and some of the [ __ ]
it's a reach it's a big [ __ ] rage
okay well maybe we should do that in the
second half well what I want to say too
is that
and here's one thing it just as an
example before we go to the break okay
so one of the prophecies that is super
super famous was this whole thing about
the death of Henry II and this was
allegedly
um you know the stories will tell you
this is the prophecy that brought him to
the attention of Catherine de Medici who
became his Patron and a big supporter of
his later on and [ __ ] like that because
he came up with this verse that had
something about you know the Young Lion
on the field of battle and like the gold
cage and the piercing the eyes and stuff
Henry remember that from the movie right
right yeah from man and saw tomorrow and
Henry II did indeed die in a jousting
match
um you know where he was pierced Through
The Eyes through his uh you know the the
visor of his helmet
um and he died like later on like nine
ten eleven days later
um so it seems to fit but the problem
with that is that one Catherine did
Medici couldn't have read that uh
supposedly at the time time because
the first time it appeared in print was
55 years after that [ __ ] happened so in
other words it's a fake quatrain it's
not fake he did write it okay but he
didn't write it before
that time or it wasn't published before
that time that that anyone has ever
found so the whole story about Catherine
de Medici reading that and thinking it
was about Henry II oh okay oh thinking
it's about her husband right that can't
be true because it wasn't published
because it wasn't published until much
later until more than 50. that quadrant
was written it was yeah okay it was
written or just the idea that Captain
manucci knew about it that's [ __ ]
yeah because she couldn't imagine
because like I said first time it
appeared in print 1614 that was the
first time they've ever found that it
appeared in print uh and that was 55
years after the death of Henry II but
you must admit that does sound like that
event it does sound like that but
like I said a lot of his [ __ ] yeah if
you can sound like anything right yeah
after the fact right yeah yeah it sounds
like it because you can't predict
anything with it so it's not any good no
you have to wait for something to happen
and then you have to stuff it into that
distributed description like I said if
you're gonna do like a prophecy and here
and here you go give me names dates give
me all that this is what I before this
is what I always thought if you knew
what you were doing you could write
things down and make statements that
eventually some [ __ ] would fit into that
yeah you know what I mean just if you
were vague enough
and that's exactly what if enough time
has passed eventually it would do that
now do I think he believed that he was
doing it I think he did I do think that
he believed yeah in it I just think that
he didn't realize the method how the
method worked I think I thought it was
paranormal but it was more statistical
you know and like I said that was the
point that Richard Wiseman was trying to
make was that you know if you make a
vague enough statement statistically
[ __ ] like that will happen at some point
that people after the fact can go like
oh that sounds like that I think me and
you are kind of aligning on this because
right Jenny and I haven't confirmed on
this
I never thought Nostradamus was a
charlatan not really I think he really
believed in what he was doing he did but
I didn't think he knew why it worked
because you're dealing with a guy of the
1500s they didn't have a real tight
understanding of Statistics I don't
think yeah if you said things a certain
way and had certain you know what I mean
yeah you could call that a fortune or a
prediction and eventually something
might fit that well and like I said
because he believed that events in the
past would repeat in the future right
and because he kept his predictions
vague they were usually about battles or
murders or you know bad [ __ ] it was
usually or disasters which that led more
Credence to my opinion
to that
Nostradamus believed in what he was
doing because if yeah he just would have
bullshitted yeah and he wasn't just
bullshitting he was trying to actually
stick to a method he was so he believed
in what he was doing I yeah I do believe
that I don't think he was like purposely
setting out to fool people into thinking
he really did believe that was the
method history is cyclical so I'm going
to look back at the past this event
happened in the past so it will happen
again it would have been much easier
just to fake it and yeah he wasn't taken
that route he was actually trying to get
it to conform to a methodology yeah
right but you know like I said because
he kept things poetical and vague yeah
um and you're dealing with the mentality
and referring to Kings and roof and
strife and royal families and things
like that which happens again and again
and you're dealing correct about you're
dealing with a 1500s mentality
their view on reality was a lot
different than ours you know but I I
don't I'm not going to say he's a fake
I'm not going to say he's a charlatan he
I think he really believed in what he
was doing
I'm just gonna say that you know I well
I think that too right because like I
said I'm not saying he's not wrong they
were just saying he did believe in it
there were easier ways to fake it yeah
he actually
if you want to say he faked he faked it
the hard way the hard way yeah there's
no reason to do it that way that's what
I mean I think he really did believe in
the method and believe in what he was
doing my superstitious ass in a certain
way might come around oh there may be
something to it
let's take a break let's take a break
all right all right so we're going to
take a break right now we will be back
in just a few minutes and talk some more
about Nostradamus and his prophecies
The Faceless villain a collection of the
eeriest unsolved murders of the 20th
century Volume 2 includes cases spanning
the years from 1960 through 1979
featuring such Infamous crimes as the
triple homicide at Lake Bodom the family
Massacre known as the good heart murders
the serial killings of the zodiac Bible
John Jack the stripper and the freeway
Phantom the slaughter of dozens of women
and girls along the highway of tears and
the Texas Killing Fields and the
mysterious death of suspected spy the
isdal woman along with dozens of other
fascinating and horrifying accounts
Buy It Now from Amazon in print Kindle
or audiobook format
wasting away in baby cookieville
looking for my lost lizards and frogs
some see us the weather's to blame but I
know
ain't no more damn frogs
no
okay everybody Jenny's got some new
shirts designs up four of them really
good ones too Atlanta Ripper who put
Bella and the witch Elm the H.H Holmes
Murder Castle and of course demon child
because man said he could these are
updated designs I think they look really
cool Jenny did a great job about him
were they fun making Jenny they were
very fun and thank you very much I think
they came out very good yeah they get
really good they're very high quality
shirts Jenny and I wear shirt uh our own
shirts at certain times when we're
trying to put a spotlight on ourselves
and you can put a spotlight on
yourselves if you go ahead and pick up
one of these shirts today you guys are
gonna love them links in the description
www.zazzle.com at 13 o'clock yes so go
check out our store at
www.zazzle.com 13 o'clock we got these
four cool new t-shirt designs plus all
our old ones if you'd rather get one of
the old ones but these ones are awesome
and you should check them out they're
also available in women's cut and they
look really cute Jenny's got some so
thank you go check them out
all right we're back look at him
drinking his cuckoo con yeah and and
vaping is that your second one uh no
same one okay
yeah talking about
Nostradamus yeah not to be confused with
Nostradamus it's right or not your
dumbass
although I guess a case could be made
for the second thing
so you know on this portion of the show
I want to kind of talk about some of his
predictions and how they turned out
should we talk about having died
yeah well just a little bit because it
wasn't really that interesting look
Nostradamus
probably not that unusual for somebody
just sat around all the time
um he had suffered from gout yeah and
arthritis for most of his life so he
actually ended up dying of what they
used to call the dropsy which is like
edema it's like fluid like accumulating
like in your body cavities and [ __ ] like
that what's that from
um from just sitting around here sitting
around doing nothing being inactive I
guess like I said you're just sitting
around being like scholarly and making
prophecy yeah a lot of those a lot of
those archaic
um
diseases are not re we don't know what
the [ __ ] they're talking about well
because nobody's lives like that
and it could have been cancer for all we
know
plus like the environment that they
lived in it's like this is what I love
about people that want to like go back
to the Middle Ages and stuff no you
don't because yeah you don't know what
they did they were doing yeah it's like
that yeah it was just like there was
poop everywhere I mean there's poop
everywhere now like poop molecules as
the as as The MythBusters showed yeah
but you know there was like literal poop
everywhere nobody wants that people used
to piss behind the curtains yeah and
there's like poop in the water supply
they didn't think anything of it just
drink it don't be a [ __ ] you know what
I mean so it's it's no wonder that
people were dying at 35 seriously how
old was he when he died more or less I
don't know he died in like uh 1566. so
he was 63 something like that which is
an old man for those days yeah I guess
it was I mean some people lived a long
time but he didn't 63. so yeah he died
and the The Story Goes that the night
before he died he told his secretary oh
I'm not going to live to see tomorrow
blah blah and then the secretary came in
and found it but you know I think the
secretary kind of made that up like
Legends would be like oh he's like he
prophesied his own death yeah no no way
to prove that yeah so
let's talk about what Nostradamus is
most famous for which is all his
prophecies and we'll talk about the man
who saw tomorrow very famous Orson
Welles documentary the funny thing about
that I watched it again today because
I've seen it since I was a kid
um this came out in 1981 when I was nine
years old and I saw it on [ __ ] HBO or
Cinemax or whatever
and it seemed totally legit the funny
thing now is like when I'm reading about
it Orson Welles and the producer of this
documentary thought it was all [ __ ]
they did they were just doing it because
hey paycheck yeah well hey you know I
think that was that was on the tale of
um there's a really famous movie called
the late great planet Earth yeah yeah
and that made a lot Lindsay Collins you
made a lot of money it freaked a lot of
people out in the theater evidently some
people couldn't sit through it they had
to leave early and people walking out
from Fright so I think
um uh The Man Who Saw tomorrow was
actually just a response to uh late
great plan it did seem like that yeah
because it was very
like it's it seemed like it was like an
hour and a half long and like you know
they're going very much into like look
at all the predictions anyway that came
true yeah and like I said the the
translations that they had were kind of
different than other ones I'd read but
the you know that kind of sounded like
they legitimately predicted stuff and
then they're kind of like oh the world's
gonna end because this came out in 1981
yeah oh the world's gonna end in 1999
well actually if I remember correctly I
said this remember when the world ended
in 1999 uh what was it the great king of
Terror from the sky from the size on the
new city and it doesn't sounds like he's
talking about the 911. and then and the
World Trade right but even in the movie
in the movie they actually showed the
twin towers and above and what looks
like a missile coming down yeah the
problem was
that well there are a lot of problems
the movie predicted it not the quad
trades yeah the the problem is like a
lot of the quadrants like I said have
been mistranslated
um you know very famously the whole line
the king of Terror yeah they think that
we're in the blue turban well they think
that that might be a mistranslation
because they're like you guys look it's
like you know the the printing press had
just been invented like when Nostradamus
was still alive right so they could
disseminate his Works to a wider
audience but the printing press still
had to be you still had to put in like
all the little type by hand you're right
yeah so when they printed the stuff like
some of the later editions and
um some of the scholars of the time were
like you know none of the additions are
the same there are misspellings they're
because you had to put the little letter
each letter in there by hand
um and particularly in French if you
leave out like an apostrophe or
something like that it's like a totally
different meaning
um and apparently the whole King Of
Terror thing was an apostrophe issue
okay
um like when there's an apostrophe in
there it could mean yes King Of Terror
when there's not an apostrophe it just
means something like the host or the
host king or something like that it
means something kind of innocuous
Nostradamus predicted it he predicted
the apostrophe error to give us
to give us the man who saw tomorrow he
even foresaw Orson wealths holy [ __ ]
even Orson Welles Orson Welles ended up
predicting the future
all right yeah he passed it off he's
like clap you know
if you're gonna if you're gonna pass the
ball or pass a torch on to somebody else
you're gonna pass it on to Orson well
yeah well you see that was the big thing
and I was telling him earlier that I had
totally forgotten about this until I was
researching the show again tonight I
watched The Man Who Saw tomorrow because
I hadn't seen it since I was a kid and I
forgot that in 1999 1991 rather they re
not remade it they re-edited it yeah
with Charlton house with the Hest yeah
with the has to like saying all of Orson
Welles lines they made it much shorter
they only made it an hour or actually
like 40 minutes and they took out some
[ __ ] that didn't happen like from the
first original one
um they made predictions that perhaps
um you know Ted Kennedy would like run
for president which he did in 1980 he
ran for the primary but he lost right
um in in the show they were saying oh
he'll run for president in 1984 that
obviously didn't happen so they took
that [ __ ] out
um they took out some other things about
um you know various things and they and
they made like they played up the whole
three Antichrist thing to make the third
Antichrist look like Saddam Hussein
because it was 1981 that was the Gulf
War so they wanted it to look like this
is like the big evil that we have to
defeat now yeah so they kind of went in
that direction
um so they took out a bunch of [ __ ]
there's if you look at the Wikipedia
page for The Man Who Saw tomorrow
because it has its own Wikipedia page
it'll show you like all the differences
between the original uh broadcast and
the later edit that they made yeah um
and it's kind of instructive to like
look at all the cuts they made because
of all the [ __ ] that wasn't successful
from the first one right but it's it's
funny to me that Orson Welles I mean he
even went on Merv Griffin the elevator
killer uh he went on Merv Griffin if you
watched him with Two Brains review
um he went on Merv Griffin Show and just
said
you know I you know he he basically
thought the whole thing was [ __ ] and
he's like you might as well just get
predictions out of like from Reading
random [ __ ] in the phone book he didn't
know 911 was gonna happen but okay well
the thing about 911
yeah but the thing about 911
is that most of the verses that quote
unquote predicted 911 yeah were hoaxes
they weren't even from they weren't they
weren't even nostradams they weren't
even enough Thomas okay they were
actually written before 9 11 but they
were written by a Canadian student
called Neil Marshall and he had written
a paper about Nostradamus and his whole
point was that I can write a verse in
this paper that is vague enough that can
refer to future events and he wrote
these particular verses and people
totally fell for it now you see there's
one way you could say it's vague okay
I Saw The Man Who Saw tomorrow
the Tiger in the blue turban the great
king of Terror right okay which at the
time when the man does he says bringing
fire down in Iran they thought yeah yeah
bringing fire down in the new city when
9 11 happened it was kind of clicked in
my head boy you know that that program
wasn't far from being wrong they got it
off a cup by a couple years but the
imagery and the idea was close
but you have to look at history
people would often exploit prophecy yeah
okay
you had a situation where Hernan Cortez
when he showed up
to Mexico in in the Mesoamerican period
you know back you know the Conquistadors
he knew about the uh Prophecies of kukul
Khan and you know
and he was making sure to fulfill those
prophecies yeah all right uh Nazis kind
of did the same thing evidently they did
yeah I mentioned that they would read uh
Nostradamus and then they would say we
are fulfilling these prophecies yeah
looks look we're gonna win all right now
you could also say that probably islamo
fascists and Islamic terrorists and
probably knew about all these prophecies
and Nostradamus and maybe they even knew
about that movie and said yeah we're
gonna blow down the World Trade Center
because uh there were a couple of other
uh Islamic terrorists that tried to take
down the World Trade Centers with a bomb
that was underneath in the parking lot
that was 93 yeah 93. so
yeah who knows if prophecy is being
fulfilled or it might be selfish people
or if people are being inspired to
fulfill that prophecy here's the thing
though the one that's kind of pointed to
as in The Man Who Saw tomorrow they were
talking about oh this is they're talking
about the end of the world the third
Antichrist with the blue turban blah
blah blah who at that time they were
referring to as Iran which like I said
that's not how that went down yeah
um but but they could say it's Mabus and
Mabus might have been an anagram for
Saddam right but mabis has been used to
refer to Osama to refer to Obama
like I said anything this vague is
useless because it can refer to anything
you want it to refer to which is why
psychics keeps it vague because of this
very reason yeah it gives you some some
wiggle room the problem about this
particular and he did actually write
this quatrain like I said he didn't
usually put dates on things even
um his much lauded uh quote-unquote
prediction of the Great Fire of London
which happened in 1666.
um even in that prediction he didn't say
1666 he said like 20 scores like 66 he
said there was no like you know first
two numbers so it could have been 1766
could have been 1866 you know he was
just lucky that it kind of happened and
he was wrong about the cause of it
because he implied that the cause of it
was lightning which it wasn't it
actually started in a bakery like in an
oven and then spread and it was three
yeah and the king of Terror thing if I
remember correctly doesn't really say
1999. it does it says the year 1999 and
seven months which is July 1999. but the
thing is this did they use the same
calendars yes people have checked that
they use the Julian calendar same and
all his almanacs uh went by the same
calendar that we used today whatever he
was talking about was July July 1998 and
the problem with this is that even
Nostradamus you know Believers right
really struggled to come up with
something that happened in July 1990 the
best they could could come up with and
this is pretty sad was that you know
what happened to July 1999 99 John F
Kennedy Jr and his wife and her sister
were killed in a plane crash
that's about it that's all they could
come up with that happened in July 1999.
great came to Tara from this guy maybe
it was a plane crash I'm like that's
pretty sad that's a breach yeah but
that's about as good as that gets
because nothing
Defender would say
no he's talking about 911 but it's off a
couple years because of something or
other that's how they're gonna uh I'll
get into the two to the September 11th
uh you know predictions later on because
like I said a lot of that was hoaxes it
wasn't even [ __ ] that Nostradamus wrote
or it was [ __ ] that Nostradamus wrote
that was mixed in with other stuff right
or some of the quatrains were mixed with
other quatrains from other centuries on
YouTube there's a channel that does
quatrains with an actor doing
nostradamus's voice evidently you can
get the whole thing on DVD but you could
also
just watch it for free on YouTube and he
reads those quadrants and the way he
delivers them they sound like that's
just gonna happen
well I think that was the problem and
like I said yeah that was a problem say
it the right way you can get it to be
like oh when I saw the man who saw
tomorrow when I was a kid I mean like I
said a lot of it had to do with the
worst yeah it's like the way he and he's
like chewing on his cigar like he was
talking and then he's like oh I guess
I'll take my cigar out some of these
princesses that he's doing right and it
sounded like all like poor scientists
and stuff like that yeah but when you
read about it later on one a lot of that
[ __ ] never happened that they said was
gonna happen
um a lot of it is like super vague and
could refer to anything and Orson Welles
himself as well as the producer did not
believe it they just did it because
money that was the thing to do yeah they
just wanted a paycheck it was good in
entertainment either I mean I wasn't
entertained by the movie
I see it again I haven't seen him
forever it's on Dailymotion I watched it
today it's on Vimeo too yeah it's
actually if you want to see it I haven't
seen the Charlton Heston one since I was
younger but he's knocking it out of the
park yeah I mean
and the way they talk about the cases
the cases in that movie it um they're
laid out
from small to large you're talking about
it they ratcheted it up with each case
yeah to try to get you to believe it
yeah you know what I mean the edit was
awesome I loved it it's a good movie is
it [ __ ] yeah probably yeah probably
yeah well like I said they all thought
it was [ __ ] yeah they're just like
we're just doing whatever we're just
making cool entertainment whatever like
I said it's you know they just even back
then I think people think like people
the [ __ ] was true back then it wasn't
they were just doing [ __ ] for money they
were doing [ __ ] to entertain people just
like Discovery Channels it had a lot to
do with late great planet Earth they
were trying to make a second version
right and that was a huge thing like in
the 70s like all that new age kind of
stuff like prophecies and all that kind
of stuff they love that kind of [ __ ]
back then
um let's talk a little bit about I'm
gonna get into the uh 911 stuff a little
bit later on and I want to get into like
the you know blowing up of the shuttle
Challenger and all that kind of stuff
because a lot of that was hoaxes let's
talk about one of his most famous
predictions that he supposedly foresaw
the coming of Hitler
so
like I said one of his most famous
things was that he supposedly like
foresaw the coming of Hitler okay um and
I've seen like I said wildly varying
translations of this particular quadrant
yeah
um one of the ones that I have before me
which is actually from uh a woman who
wrote a book about him you know in the
70s the translation says beasts wild
with Hunger will cross the rivers the
greater part of the battle will be
against history although she says Hitler
but that's not what he said he said
hister he will cause great men to be
dragged in a cage of iron when the son
of Germany obeys no law I've seen
various like I said translations of this
all yeah now this is an English
translation from archaic French probably
mixed with some other [ __ ] with some
other [ __ ] yeah so so the biggest
problem with this one a lot of that is
like super vague yeah and nobody was
dragged in any cages or anything and the
problem with
history
he wasn't referring to a person that was
a section of the lower Danube and he had
actually referred to it in other
quatrains like in earlier centuries that
he had published I thought it was a
river
um it was like it was a river yeah
sectional lower Danube like I said
that's a river
um so he was actually talking about a
region not a person
so there's that whole thing uh you know
about that there were a couple of other
quatrains you know there's one in this
book here that was like uh that says
near the Rhine from the Austrian
Mountains will come a great man of the
people come too late a man who will
defend Poland and Hungary and whose fate
will never be certain but the thing
about it like I said a lot of these
translations are one incorrect right and
are based on later
extrapolation and Hitler didn't come
from Germany he came from Austria yeah
but where was what were the borders of
Germany in in nostradamus's time did
that also include oh I'm not sure
actually so maybe that could work but
that's very vague that's what I mean
that's kind of the problem and like I
said this is a problem I have with a lot
of uh prophecy type stuff and we talked
about this a little bit on our Edgar
Casey I mean a man from Germany defends
Hungary and Poland yeah that could that
would probably happen to many many times
over in history well that time and like
I said I think that when Nostradamus was
writing he was actually poetically
writing about something that had already
happened that he thought was going to
happen again in the future so I think
that he wrote it in such a manner that
it could be interpreted as happening
again later on like I said after the
fact you can kind of squeeze it into
anything you want to squeeze it in and
then they're seeing interpretation was
Hitler defending Poland
you know what I mean in Hungary or did
he invade and subjugate Poland and
Hungary it depends on your point of view
yeah you would argue the latter well
there were also pro-hitler people in the
both of those two countries yeah
obviously so but it's just difficult to
say
I'm just sure that there were many times
in history where there were Warlords
from Germany they had defended Poland
and Hungary in some way yeah you know
it's just too vague
that's what I mean and that is kind of
the problem that I have and as I was
re-watching The Men Who Saw tomorrow
earlier today
um I was kind of realizing like stuff
that seemed really significant to me as
a kid and particularly in this book too
like I said strange Shore is amazing
facts which has like a lot of his
quote-unquote quatrains and um you know
kind of relating them to events in
history like you know Edward the eighth
and how he abdicated the throne so he
could marry uh Wallace Simpson and
things like that
um most of the quatrains are so
they just could they could refer to any
number of things and that's not even
taking into account how maybe they were
mistranslated maybe there was a misprint
maybe because there's more than one
language because there's more than one
and and honestly I've seen like uh
Scholars of ancient French Scholars of
Nostradamus have said they have never
seen an edition of his works that is the
same
so yeah saying so and like I said even
something as small as an apostrophe or
just a letter change or something like
that could change the entire meaning so
even in that in Antiquity Nostradamus
books depending on what language they
were in are different
they're different even in the same
language even in the same language
they're different okay because like I
said that really throws at the time you
know the like I said type setting was
hand you had to hand put all the letters
into the Press right and it's like if
something if someone in another city was
doing it and like left out an apostrophe
or left out a letter or something like
that it would change the entire meaning
of it and like I said Nostradamus
Scholars have said they've never seen an
edition of his works and they don't
really have any super original ones
there were some that came out like maybe
like when he was older like right after
he died that's like the earliest ones
but most of the later ones he's like
they are all different he's like I've
never seen any that are the same that
leads me to believe that there were
Regional preferences
exactly in other words you guys over in
another part of town says I think I want
this prophecy is about
and like you said when you were talking
about the Nazis yeah I mean they knew
about Nostradamus they knew about that
prophecy they manipulated them and they
manipulated it to look like like they
were gonna come like they were gonna win
and that they printed it on flyers and
dropped it like from Planes
so you can like manipulate things to
kind of say whatever you want it to say
yeah that's what I'm arguing yeah the uh
the Nazis were telling people that
Nostradamus had predicted and predicted
that their victories yeah because they
were trying to demoralize right the
enemies like look it's a foregone
conclusion we're going to win so you
might as well just give up that's what
they were hoping would happen and like I
said even even when the even when the
[ __ ] didn't seem to say that they won
which it didn't really they kind of like
massaged it to kind of sound like that
and it's it's my recollection that the
the quatrans that the Nazis were using
had nothing to do with the quatrans that
we used to talk about the Nazis it had
something to do with some battle that
was going to happen yeah you know well
like I said most of his [ __ ] was so
vague and he he would kind of Hit the
same themes over and over again like
battles he would um a lot of the
underlying themes of his quatrains were
oh Muslims are invading Europe but that
was because that's been going on forever
right but that was because of like the
ottoman Invasion and stuff which was
going on in his time right so he was
just kind of like projecting that into
the future so you know whenever it seems
like he was super prescient about you
know this that or the other happening
it's just he was taking things from the
past writing about it in a vague type of
way that could have referred to a lot of
things you know King's yeah earthquakes
floods you know diseases diseases and
you know [ __ ] like that battles it's
like that happens all the time another
thing another thing is is that there
were so many quatrains out there that
are so obscure and so vague they're
never discussed and you read them and
you're like what is that yeah we're only
talking about the quatrains that
actually kind of line up with things
that we know from pop culture yeah
because there were most of them almost a
thousands yes most of them are not that
most of them are things that no one
talks about it and even the best ones
that they pick out is like oh doesn't
this sound like this and that to me they
just sound very big almost like a reach
you know what I mean and like I was
saying before the break some of them are
outright hoaxes
for example the ones that were referring
to September 11th now shortly after
September 11th occurred
some supposedly
not sure how Miss penned quatrains made
their way around the internet now these
supposedly said in the year of the new
century in nine months from the sky will
come a great king of Terror that sounds
familiar doesn't it yeah this guy will
burn at 45 degrees fire approaches the
great new city in the city of York there
will be a great collapse no that was not
in the original right torn apart by
chaos while the Fortress Falls the great
leader will succumb third big war will
begin with the big cities burning now
the problem with this is that
in the year of the new century in nine
months that is a fabrication
yeah it wasn't in there that came from
the original quatrain about 1999 and the
seven months the great they changed it
that and that was changed to more suit
uh 911 right this guy will burn at 45
degrees I didn't say this that is a
later uh fabrication or it was taken
from another quatrain and like squashed
into this one
um because people were like oh 45
degrees New York City is at 40 degrees
and 47 minutes like latitude or
longitude or whatever it is
um which you know whatever now the
problem is that whenever Nostradamus and
he did refer to New City sometimes and I
feel like a lot of people think that
he's talking about New York he's not
talking about New York he's talking
about Naples Naples uh the Greek name of
Naples actually means new city uh so
whenever he talks about new city and
like fire and blah blah he's talking
about Vesuvius uh which actually is near
Naples and sometimes erupted and like
[ __ ] [ __ ] up so that's used usually
what he's talking about well you know
and Nostradamus fan is going to say oh
no that's not what he's talking about it
has a double meaning
of course you can say that well like I
said and I don't remember I I don't
remember making an analogy right you
know I don't remember who it was that
said this it was I I want to say it was
Carl Sagan but I think maybe not but
um Believers in this type of thing are
like what he called Unsinkable rubber
ducks it's like no matter what you come
up with it's like they'll just come back
up and just be like no but blah blah
because they want to believe it so bad
so they'll always like come up with
something else Beijing wants me wants to
go out okay laughs
but yeah so as I mentioned earlier
um a lot of those two quatrains were
invented and they were invented on
purpose uh by a Canadian student who had
actually written a paper about
Nostradamus and wanted to make the point
that if you wrote something that sounded
prophetic and sounded like something
that nostromus could have written that
people would pick it up and run with it
and they would apply it to you know
later just kind of have an experiment so
yeah he did write it prior to 911 but he
deliberately wrote it to be vague enough
that it could refer to pretty much
anything
um this gets to what I wanted to say
yeah I believe that Nostradamus was
doing this on purpose as part of a
method yeah but I also believed he
thought that that was predicting the
future I don't think he thought he did
yeah he did yeah like I said I I think
that was part of his
um science that was part of his
quote-unquote both sides right yeah that
you can predict the future by being
vague astrology and like I said history
history is cyclical therefore it follows
right that if I look at a time in
history where
Mars and Venus and Jupiter were in a
particular alignment if I look into the
future and this particular alignment
happen again then this [ __ ] will happen
again so I'm going to protect it but so
what that means intelligently he didn't
put dates on stuff right so what that
means well he knew he couldn't do it
that well right what that means is that
he was not a charlatan or a fake and
what it means is that he was a man
applying
a
um a pseudoscience is what he was trying
to apply a pseudoscience right to
reality yeah thinking that it's real
yeah yeah that's what I think was going
on the problem with a lot of this kind
of stuff and it's sad because it's still
even in this day and age when we have
all of this amazing uh technology and
knowledge at our fingertips
um it does seem like a lot of people
still believe in this [ __ ] because I
mean just a random uh search of YouTube
is like Nostradamus predictions for 2019
came up with all kind of crazy [ __ ] and
I was like I think the thing is I have
to admit I I used to do that kind of
stuff well here's the thing and like I'm
not a psychologist
um but I'm gonna say I think it's
because
human beings are very uncomfortable with
uncertainty they don't like knowing
what's not what's going to happen in the
future they want to have a handle on
things it's like you know I can control
things I can control the environment I
can control this and that but because
they know deep down that they can't
um then they're looking for some way
that will give them kind of
an edge or a knowledge of like I know
what's going to happen in the future
Nostradamus said this and that yeah yeah
so therefore that's what's gonna happen
that's kind of the way I used to
approach it yes Thomas had to say about
this right can I get a heads up can I
yeah can I see what will happen and I
think that's a very common I I just
think that's the way the human brain
works it's the same thing as a horoscope
if you're doing your horoscope it's the
exact same right thing you know they're
vague you can read into them and you
know you'll feel better like yeah I know
what's going on yeah that's all it is I
think it's all it is because it's like a
probability yeah and like I said it's
it's because you know I I don't have
this because I'm perfectly fine with not
knowing what's gonna happen that's
that's fine with me but looks like I
know that that's not a common thing it's
a very human thing to want to have
control over your environment control
over or feel at least feel like you have
control over what's going to happen and
if you know that you don't have control
over what's going to happen then you
have to have all these kind of like
methods of figure it's the same you know
it's the same thing as like
you know what we call quote unquote
primitive tribes when they go out
fishing or they go out like doing
something that's going to like feed
their families they have all these
rituals it's like well you know I have
to have this on my boat or I have to
have this particular lucky thing because
you know that'll fix everything or I
have to pray to this particular God or
whatever to make you feel better and in
some ways it does work because it makes
you more confident right so it almost
seems like a self-fulfilling prophecy
because it does make things work a
little bit better because you're more
confident or whatever but I mean it's an
illusion right but it's a helpful
illusion yeah it's like you read a you
see something happen you say well you
say well what did Nostradamus say about
that right and you find some quadrant
that's kind of related you go well it's
gonna be okay yeah and you're gonna
finish okay even though I should say
that like yeah here's the thing when I
watched The Man Who Saw tomorrow I was
like I've forgotten how apocalypse oh
yeah it's apocalyptic yeah this shit's
over with yeah yeah 1999 the world's
gonna end you guys because this came out
in 1981 so it was like that was many
years away it's like you know now 1999
it was like a long time ago and
obviously nothing bad happened oh the
Millennium was like man the world might
end yeah I remember you had Arnold
Schwarzenegger saying this
was end of days can I just say for the
record though I never devil might show
up I never thought and then you had then
you had you had what was it the big
computer uh problem uh Y2K yeah I like
y2k2k I didn't think anything was good
see I'm not saying that to be a hipster
I I really did not think anything bad
was gonna happen because every single
time
some stupid [ __ ] comes out and
it's like the world's gonna end all this
bad shit's gonna happen I'm like no it's
not just stop yeah and then it's just
the Mayan calendar thing with 2012 and
Nostradamus got like [ __ ] roped into
that too even though he made no
predictions about 2012. but you know
what he said the world was going to end
in 37.97 okay
okay well here's the thing 1999 it was
just supposed to be the Great War a lot
of that chocolate a lot of that
apocalyptic stuff though I kind of took
comfort in it yeah this shit's going all
the oldest oh it's all gonna be over
soon that's we had to worry about it I
took comfort in the fact I only half
believed it though only half of it I
only took I didn't take comfort and I
just thought you're full of [ __ ] like
every other person that said that like
in the history of ever to me it was just
kind of like a fun thing to believe in
or at least the anxiety was kind of it's
kind of fun to have a little bit of the
oh something I haven't
like I said foreign
for the record it's like every time and
and instantly like the second like
somebody comes out like on YouTube or
like on the news or whatever it's like
oh this horrible bad thing is gonna
happen on this date or whatever I'm just
like yeah nothing's gonna happen it's
fine it's like yeah bad [ __ ] can happen
but it's like apocalyptic world and
that's just been happening for tens of
thousands of years that's what I mean
it's like it seems like somebody that
doesn't know anything about history yeah
or doesn't have like a long-term view is
it it's funny I was just reminded of
like this one time
I was at my grandmother's house or
something like that and these two
[ __ ] Jehovah's Witnesses came to my
door it's like two little old ladies
right and I don't like to be well okay
this isn't entirely true I was gonna say
I don't like to be an [ __ ] sometimes
I do but these two little old ladies and
I felt bad for them so they came to the
door and they're Jehovah's Witnesses or
Mormons or whatever the [ __ ] they were
and they're trying to tell me how like
oh well don't you think the world is
going to end like look at this that and
the other thing like there were whatever
that was in the news at that particular
time and I said to them I'm like yeah
but that's been happening since forever
yeah the world is always ending like do
you not realize that or anything and
then they got like super mad at me and I
was just like whoa I don't I don't get
why they don't understand that well it's
the end of the world as you know it
here's the weird thing is that the world
as you know it is always ending because
the future is always coming that's what
I mean things that you know now will not
be applicable too much so in the future
like I said so everything is apocalyptic
you're always good exactly you can
always have that apocalyptic feeling you
can have that but it's like see I don't
have that like I said I'm not as much as
I love you know and think about how much
the world has changed since the 1990s
right but you know what I mean I didn't
find it particularly upsetting no it's
not upsetting but you know we never the
World As We Knew It is gone yeah so in a
way this is the apocalypse but that's
what happened that's how it goes that's
how it rolls and that's how it rolls
with every generation and I don't
understand why that's so upsetting it's
not upsetting it's not upsetting some
people some people have kind of an
anxiety about the world that they like
that's happening now will end it will
yeah because the world has always
changing but that isn't inevitability it
doesn't mean that the world of the
future you won't enjoy it that doesn't
mean that it just means we'll see that's
the way because here's the thing like
you know like you I grew up in the 70s
and 80s there was some Brad [ __ ] about
that time I still like a lot of like
movies and music and [ __ ] from that time
but one I can still listen to that so
it's fine
um two it's like a lot of [ __ ] nowadays
is a lot better than I wanted back then
and I've said this many times on our
shows a lot better I never ever
would have been able to foresee the
impact of the internet nobody did yeah
nobody did God damn if anybody said they
did there's like something out of my
wildest dreams
but it's cool though because yeah yeah
well I think it's because like my I have
a particular personality type where like
I'm a very laid back I know this is hard
to say because I'm like super stressed
out all the time but I'm in general I'm
a very laid back kind of person about
like [ __ ] that happens I'm just kind of
like
[ __ ] happens and I'm like okay well now
we need to readjust to deal with that
[ __ ] that happened I'm not gonna get
upset I'm not a nostalgic person
um I'm not kind of a person that's like
oh we should go back to the old way of
doing this like no I don't want to do
that [ __ ] I would not go back to the 70s
I would not go back to the 80s I would
not I lived through it I wouldn't I'm
nostalgic but I don't want to go back to
those days I like to look back at those
days and see the progress that we've
made you know what I mean all right
that's it and I like to like imagine I
like to imagine myself back in the 80s
looking forward to now
yeah about how futuristic it really is I
do kind of find that an interesting
thought experiment here's the thing like
okay Charles Darwin is like a big hero
of mine and I always like sometimes when
I've read some of his writings I'm like
I wonder if like if I can invent a time
machine and go back and get Charles
Darwin and bring him to this day and age
like what would he say like I'd be
really interested yeah like I'd be
interested to see like what his
reactions would be like what he would
react to
um but other than that I'm a very roll
with it kind of person it's just like
whatever happens I'm just gonna roll
with that I saw some science fiction
from the 1920s some movies that kind of
predicted
cross between television and um
uh Skype where you can look into a
screen and talk well the Jetsons kind of
and then they could they could talk to
the world why something was happening uh
but in that same movie and I forgot the
name it was all black and white movie
from the 20s it didn't really fully was
it the shape of things to come I think
so yeah it didn't yeah it didn't fully
address what the impact on society would
be
if you had internet technology you know
what I mean but still 1920s right yeah
we'll see and that's why I never get all
head up about yeah you know people
getting outraged about this and the
other oh it was going to be the end of
the world blah blah because there's too
many one there's too many contingencies
you can never like I said no one
predicted the internet no one predicted
um you know some people predicted
something kind of like it but nobody
predicted the impact that would have
like the changes it would there's too
many contingencies along the way that
you can't predict so it's pointless to
try to predict things I think there's
another thing is that we talk about like
the fall of societies in like a
post-apocalyptic end of the world if
there were an apocalyptic situation to
happen now
that would say the United States were to
fall and collapse and go into chaos yeah
a lot of people would die
but it wouldn't be like what you're
seeing on Mad Max that wouldn't happen
no I don't believe that no could because
you can't erase that knowledge and you
couldn't erase all that technology
exactly you would still have high
technology yeah you'd have a
post-apocalyptic society that had a lot
of Education a lot of knowledge you may
not have the internet but you'd have all
these books and then quickly the
internet would just come back right
because there'd be computers around yeah
and you'd have solar technology in a
smaller population a smaller and smarter
population because you'd have gone
through like an edge you've gone through
a bottle deck right uh so
uh an apocalypse would not be moving
would not be mankind moving backwards an
apocalypse nowadays probably would mean
mankind taking a Leap Forward
you know yeah you have a smaller
population with less load on it
with strong intelligent people with
access to a technology
picking it up and then like two
generations later you'd be back in a
high-tech world with a very small I feel
like because I feel like a lot of the
[ __ ] that is not taken into account is
that you know yeah oh we get bombed to
[ __ ] and everybody goes back to cavemen
but that wouldn't happen because
people's brains are not caveman brains
right yeah we've we've descended along
this particular we know things Rome fell
uh you have Middle Ages Europe all that
[ __ ] fell and Technology continued to
move forward and knowledge continued to
move forward it never really went
backwards people knew all for the most
part nowadays know all that stuff we
have the accumulated yeah and there's
too many machines laying around and
there's too many books laying around now
what you couldn't erase knowledge like
you could back in the past yeah it's
it's not the same it's not comparable so
like I said and like I said I feel like
it's impossible to predict things
because there's too many historical
contingencies too many little too many
um large historical events have hinged
on like little tiny like unpredictable
you know little things that happen so I
feel like it's pointless to try to you
know extrapolate what's going to happen
in the future it's like most people that
try to extrapolate in the future just
get it drastically drastically wrong so
I just feel like it's it's a wasted
Enterprise I just don't see any value
okay back to Nostradamus or anything so
okay we're going to talk a little bit
about
there were a couple of uh hoaxes like I
said just like the September 11th hoax
uh there was also one about the space
shuttle Columbia exploding
um shortly after the space shuttle
Columbia exploded uh a supposedly uh
nostradamian uh quatrainian made the
rounds that said in the mission of the
first blue star a child of the Holy Land
among the seven Shall Perish as the ship
descends Heaven Sky the Lone Star be
scattered with wreckage now a lot of
people pointed and I saw a lot of
Nostradamus sites and said oh we've
predicted the Columbia disaster blah
blah 1986.
um this was also a hoax although they're
not quite sure where it came from but
it's not in any of nostradamuses uh
original things and uh you know this
sound didn't sound like a Nostradamus
yeah but like I said they're they're
trying to make the point that it's very
easy to write something in that vein
that sounds like it refers to something
you know yeah uh there was also one one
this one kind of cracked me up when
George W Bush was elected in uh 2000 uh
another quatrain made the rounds that
said come to Millennium month 12 in the
home of greatest power The Village Idiot
will come forth to be acclaimed later
which somebody wrote as a joke and then
like a lot of people like picked it up
yeah that just sounds too contemporary
right exactly there was also a true
quadrant didn't sound that precise that
yeah you were all over the place exactly
that's what I mean there was also one
about uh the guy that wrote Gangnam
Style I don't know why is everybody a
Korean guy because yeah because some
people said like when his uh the the
implication was that when his video got
a billion views on YouTube the world
would end right but it has got a million
videos so far and the world is still
trucking along as far as we know unless
we're in The Matrix or something so uh
that was obviously the world's not gonna
end people yeah it's yeah and we did an
end of the world prediction show totally
it's it's fine there's only one way the
world could ever end and that would be
some kind of a like a deep impact from
some kind of large that's what I mean
which could happen that could happen but
it's unlikely at this point it's
unlikely and if it did happen like we
probably wouldn't know about it until
like a few days before and a couple days
morning and there'd be nothing well
there wouldn't be anything you'd do
about it so I I just feel like that's
you know it's it's not productive to
like worry about that kind of [ __ ] yeah
but um yeah so
as I said we're kind of talking a little
bit about the man who saw it tomorrow
and they're kind of like predicting the
end of the world in 1999. now I did look
up because I had to do it for this show
I was like so what are the predictions
for 2019 because you know that all the
Paranormal sites are all the Nostradamus
are there to predictions for 2009 of
course there's predictions for every
year
well like I said yeah well he wrote his
centuries okay we're up until like I
said he said the end of the world was
going to be 37.97 okay for the next 2000
years from when he uh first started
writing them in the 1500s so he made
predictions for like every year I've
been because I thought the centuries
were vague in the order that they are
they are vague so a century could be any
time you wanted to be pretty much okay
and I feel like that's kind of what
that's what so I said like okay so I was
like shortly before I recorded the show
I said I'm gonna look up what the
predictions for this year are and we'll
see how if it's actually for this year
because like I said we'll see how
accurate yeah it is Okay so
predictions for predictions for 2018
from the Nostradamus websites y'all
um again we're predicting World War III
which I think they've been predicted
every year since 1999. this is a war
that's going to last 27 years which
again was the same thing that they
predicted when the world was going to
end in 1999 which didn't happen
um supposedly this big thing it's like
oh the US and the Russia and they're
gonna like unite and like fight against
the Antichrist or whatever yeah that's
not going on forever yeah so that like I
said that's the same thing they're
predicting every year since 1999.
we'll see if that happens 2019 yeah
um also there there's a prediction of a
gigantic earthquake like like 8.5 on the
Richter scale that will occur between
California and Vancouver Island so look
out for that uh at some point there's
also supposed to be massive flooding uh
in Europe particularly in Hungary Italy
the Czech Republic in Great Britain so
we'll see if that happens this year
um some more positive developments that
are supposed to happen this year
according to Nostradamus this year we're
supposed to be able to start to
communicate with animals what
communication well I'm just saying well
okay the the quatrains say
basically the pigs will become brothers
to man
okay which could be interpreted in a lot
of different ways like we're gonna stop
eating pork we're gonna start talking to
pigs like because I'm gonna say like
talking to animals like yeah I already
do that
I already talked to my cat or are they
talking about certain and she kind of
understands that they talk about certain
political parties being friends with you
now or what are they talking about see
that's they mean that's another
literally or they mean the people you
think are pigs that's what I mean they
could be you don't know you don't know
you don't know too vague so yeah so
other people have said oh this is the
Year everyone goes vegetarian because we
don't eat pigs anymore or you know this
is year we start talking to animals like
[ __ ] Doctor Doolittle I don't [ __ ]
know
um also supposedly this year medicine is
supposed to advance to a point where
people are gonna live to 200 years old
they ain't gonna have no I don't think
they're gonna happen either
um also another prediction that was made
for this year
uh and the the quatrain supposedly says
and this is like I said translation I
don't know how accurate this is
after a new engine will appear the world
will be as in the days before Babel
meaning some people will say oh it's
like the internet oh he's talking about
the internet
but see
that's not what they're talking about
see this is why I have problems with
this kind of [ __ ] and this is why I have
problems with all of this psychic kind
of [ __ ] and all this prophecy kind of
[ __ ] because that's awful vague
yeah and like new engine all of his kind
of like new engine that could mean
anything that could mean anything yeah
that can be in a car engine like made a
plane engine that could mean the new
electric engine in the Harley Live Wire
because that's coming out because you
know if you're so inclined yeah you're
always talking about the internet yeah
oh he predicted that [ __ ] but see this
is the okay in my life I have been to
exactly one psychic
um I went I don't know if you guys know
if you're not from Florida but there's a
town here called Cassadaga and uh it's a
spiritualist Enclave
so you can still go there it's actually
kind of a tourist area now but you can
go there and it's like a lot of
spiritualists and psychics and whatnot
um so I went there several years ago
with my mother and some of her aunts
because they're like oh let's go to
Cassadaga it'll be fun we'll go to the
psychic or whatever
um so it's this kind of [ __ ] you go to
the psychic and they say some vague
[ __ ] that could kind of apply to
anybody or anything
but it kind of sounds like also it could
apply to you
yeah and then you leave I mean not me
because I don't believe that kind of
[ __ ] but if you're inclined to believe
that kind of [ __ ]
then you'll leave thinking man
she got me she knew what I was talking
about
like I said I go to the sidekick all she
said about me was well you look like a
person of an artistic demeanor which
probably anybody would know if they were
just looking after right you have
artistic demeanor yeah because you know
like I look like a goth chick it's like
you know anybody would call that pretty
much if they were paying attention and
that was pretty much all she she said
that and she said oh you have a
red-headed Angel like or a redheaded
Spirit like watching over you and at the
time before I dyed my hair my hair is
naturally red so somebody in your face
she's just assuming that it was like a
relative so like I said me being a
skeptic I immediately twigged to like
well obviously I look like a god person
and I have red hair so she just picked
up on two major things about me and like
extrapolated from that
and I feel like that's what a lot of
like I said I don't think Nostradamus
was deliberately bullshitting I think he
did believe what he was doing but in
later years I think people are taking
his [ __ ] and retro fitting it back into
events that they wanted to be because
I've seen the same quatrains applied to
different things in history and it could
fit just as well he's using a
methodology to scry yeah that's what
he's doing yeah and they found out that
the more explicit you were and ascribe
the less chances it would actually
happen right and that the more vague you
were the more chances it would seem to
be fulfilled and that's what they're
doing that's what he's doing and I feel
certain art to it now here's another
thing he realized you can make money
with this
so we haven't really gotten into this
yet you had rich people they would want
you to come and basically tell fortunes
yeah which is what he generally made his
money doing sure and did reports and
whatnot his name survives today because
he was probably good at it he was quite
famous at the time even even in France
like his International Fame didn't
really grow until later on after he was
dead after the publication of his stuff
so just like a horoscope you have to be
able to
look at somebody's signs and then come
out with a with a prediction that's
vague enough but then kind of tailored
around the person you're talking about
to make it fulfill itself
that's what he's doing have you ever
seen it after it happens you go I was
right yeah see it did happen and not
even expect it to go that way
and it's it's a mind [ __ ] really yeah
okay
these guys are not totally analytical
they're not the modern analytical mind
of where they're gonna sit around and go
oh what I did was it was just a
probability thing I painted this picture
of course it's going to happen most
likely that's not how they're looking at
it they're looking at it as well it's a
miracle yeah it's a miracle well because
like I said if you're a psychic uh you
know and the ones that are still alive
now Sylvia Brown died didn't she but I
think yeah she was a fake though well it
does yeah but uh they're all fixed yeah
yeah yeah
is he still alive I don't know well
here's the thing is that these modern
people doing this okay should know
better and I believe most of them do
know I think the modern ones but but
Nostradamus came from a time where I
don't think they knew better
they didn't that's what I mean that's
why I'm not attributing like nefarious
um you know purposes to him because
this was a legitimate like way of
seeking knowledge it was a much easier
way to do what he was doing and still
make the money if he wanted a [ __ ]
he could have done that much easier all
right I I do feel like he had a
methodology for doing things and he went
around like I said you know oh I'm going
to look into the future of this
particular year whatever so I'm going to
look back at the astrological records of
like when the planets were in this
particular alignment what happened that
year I'm going to extrapolate forward
and say maybe that will happen
conforming to science he has a system he
is it's a system right yeah so it's not
like he was just pulling stuff out of
his ass he did actually have a system
and he thought that it was legitimate he
thought it was working and it made sense
with all the other sciences that they
knew at the time which would have been
astrology right basically but he was
smart enough to know that he needed to
couch it in vague enough terms that it
could be interpreted in lots of
different ways because like I said if
you're writing prophecies and if your
prophecy can be kind of put into several
different events then that's obviously
not a very good prophecy because right
it's too vague to be an event I don't
think that's how they saw it no I don't
see it that way they thought that it had
to be vague for it to be an actual
prophecy right I think they thought that
was how that was the method by which it
would come yeah you know what I mean
because we're looking at it from a
modern person that well you're not
explicit yeah so it's not an act they
didn't see it that way yeah I don't
think they saw it that way because I
mean he very very rarely came up with
like a year
where yeah like I said people are like
very oh we said 1999 but like I said he
was he's like I'll be dead what the hell
do I care like what happened
yeah be a long dick I'll be long dead no
one will care it's like you know yeah he
came up with 66 for the great fire or
whatever but it's like that could have
been any time I was gonna say I know
you're probably pretty drunk right now
but would you like to make sure my legs
are [ __ ] okay would you like to make
any Nostradamus style predictions about
the future it doesn't have to be this
year it could be many years from now no
one will know make some predictions for
after you're dead
so that people will look back on this
podcast I can't do that and be like
nostrad Thomas
predicted on the seventh and the other
on the seventh Moon it will rise
on the seventh yeah the seventh moon
this is pretty good it sounds like
Nostradamus already may he see his own
nostrad Thomas
demise
[Laughter]
I don't know man I'm just making this
that was pretty good actually yeah well
like I said as long as you're related to
like someone's death or like a battle
yeah or you know someone taking over
another thing or like you can't go wrong
with that kind of [ __ ] because that
shit's always happening right humans as
much as they like to think they're
complex and stuff we we follow very
predictable patterns yeah and as long as
you stick to this predictable patterns
you're probably pretty safe like I said
all your psychics now is even [ __ ]
Sylvia Brown before she's croaked
um
you know how hard can it be to like
predict oh there'll be upheaval in the
Middle East yeah no [ __ ] yeah there'll
be earthquakes yeah no [ __ ] yeah no [ __ ]
there'll be a disease that spread that
could like refer to anything so just
keep it like that
and you're golden right you're golden
just you know yeah Pro tip for any
second in the modern mind grasps why
this works very easily yeah but I don't
think the medieval yeah I don't think or
the uh Renaissance mind really was
really uh hip with the idea of
statistical probabilities yeah and I
don't even think most modern people
understand it's a probability honestly
poetic language that could have many
different interpretations would help you
be accurate in your in your predictions
because he never like I said he very
rarely he very rarely referred to a date
or a year he very rarely referred to
People by name now we can take this into
like Pro in the modern sense in projects
Stargate with remote viewing they said
the less precise you are the more
accurate you will be but only after the
effect when in remote viewing that is a
very that is a very accurate assessment
and nostradamus's prediction right all
right the vager you are the more
accurate you are yeah but only after the
[ __ ] only after the effect and I feel
like um I looked up uh the Nostradamus
entry on Skeptics dictionary and they
said pretty much the exact same thing
they said all his followers like you
know they're very into like the magic
aspect of his like his stuff is like
super vague until after the fact when it
becomes crystal clear
you go what a master then you go wow he
figured that [ __ ] out because you know
this [ __ ] already happened but like I
said nobody predicted anything
beforehand right and as I said prophecy
is useless
if you can't prevent something from
happening you're not something from
happening you're not seeing the future
in the future you're only you're only
telling what happened in the past yeah
and I think that's kind of the case here
sorry an astronomist I know you've been
dead for several several centuries but I
feel the need to even though I think I
still think he thought he was doing some
serious [ __ ] I do too I do too like I
said it's
just do I think that he believed that he
had powers that he believed he was legit
yeah I do believe he that he did believe
it
was it correct no no but I don't think
he was deliberately trying to defraud
anyone I really don't yeah I don't think
so
so you know that's
it's maybe a distinction without a
difference but I'm gonna say that anyway
now I don't think he was deliberately
trying to like [ __ ] anyone over
he really did think he could predict the
future because of his little method it
was another time yeah exactly oh let's
wrap this up all right so we're wrapping
up the show on Nostradamus hopefully you
guys have enjoyed it um I predict that
you did enjoy it
I'm just gonna say some [ __ ] about some
vague battle somewhere and blah blah all
right so remember if you like the show
like share subscribe on all your social
media if you'd like to financially
support the show which would be much
appreciated you can go to our patreon
page patreon.com 13 o'clock podcast or
if you don't like patreon for whatever
reason you can go to our blog which is
13
o'clockpodcast.wordpress.com and there's
a link in the sidebar to a PayPal
account where you can give a one-time
donation if you'd like to do that also
remember to check out our last movie
review which was deep red AKA profonda
Rosso the giallo directed by Diario
Argento and remember to check out our
shows Tuesday Friday Sunday you know
check them all out
and this will do it for episode 129 we
will see you next time bye
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign